Hey what's up my friends, happy Easter
today we are going to be dipping chocolate Easter eggs
but we are going to be doing it with a "King Of Random" twist
Now for this video I went down to the grocery store
and picked up a bunch of these Cadbury Creme Eggs that come out this time of year
and the purpose of this video is really to have fun,
but there are 3 main experiments I'd like to try today
The first experiment is freezing a Cadbury Creme Egg in liquid nitrogen,
and cutting it open to see what it looks like
The second experiment is taking one of these Black Cat fireworks,
sticking it inside and letting it off
And for the third experiment we're going to take another one of those firecracker Creme Eggs and
soak it in liquid nitrogen
just to see if it'll work
So I picked up the classic Creme Eggs, but I also noticed they had a caramel variety as well
So to get started, let's crack them open, just to see the difference between these two
Uh, these things are sticky!
There we go
Oh, the caramel isn't quite as sticky
That's nice
So I got these thing unwrapped, and at first glance, they look nearly identical
So for our next step, why don't we take a utility knife
to cut along the seams to cut these things open and see how they compare inside
Ooo! Look at that! Ooo, Wow!
Very Cool!
Hmm, it cracked right open
more like broke open, haha
Love my job!
So there's there's the difference guys,
so the first one looks more like an egg, got the egg white, with the yellowish yolk in the center
and I'm not sue if that's actually a yolk shape originally, or if it's just globed in there
But this other one surprises me, I was expecting this to be more of the egg white with, uh, caramel yolk center
But you can see that whole thing is filled entirely with caramel
and it'll be interesting to see what caramel does after it's been cryogenically frozen
Cool! So now that we know these things are supposed to look like on the inside, let's get dipping them in liquid nitrogen
For this experiment I'm just using a standard  Styrofoam glass
Surprisingly, Styrofoam is a very, very, good insulator, much better than plastic that would just crack and spill the nitrogen
and even better than glass that would boil quite a bit of it off, and I'm still able to hold it without much difficulty
All right, here we go for the first dip, and for this one, I think were going to keep the wrapper on
Living on the edge
All right, here we go!
When I dunk, you dunk, we dunk, and we have contact
Haha! Look at all the heat
It's like bubbling and foaming
Make sure we don't spill any over the edge there
There we go
Now I'm going to let that soak for about a minute, so it has a chance to freeze
all the way through
and when it comes out, I imagine it's going to be rock hard, it's not going to be very easy to cut through
So in the meantime I'm going to go grab a bench vise and a hacksaw so we can get the leverage we need to chop this thing open and see what it looks like inside
Ok, cool, guys, we're pushing up on almost three minutes now, hpefully that's enough time for this
I'm going to take this out,
and look, as soon as it comes out, it looks completely clean, no problem. But instantly you can see it starts frosting over, and I can actually hear the chocolate cracking a little bir as well. So,
before this thing warms up too much, let's get over to the bench vise, and chop it open with our hacksaw
Alright, going into the bench vise now, I'm going to try and line this up so it goes along the seam
the best we can
luckily it hasn't started frostbiting my fingers too much
Oh, shoot!
Hahaha
Dang it! This is harder than I thought
Yeah, ok. So maybe we should just break these things open
I'm so tempted to put that in my mouth right now, I don't know if I should
So update, guys
The bench vise is a little bit too much pressure for this thing, so for this one, we're going with the good old hammer and chisel
Cool
Set that guy right there, hold that with my knee, and
Wow! Well, I think either way, these things just crumble, but you can get a pretty good visual on what's inside there
I was hoping there was actually like, uh, yellow egg yolk inside there, but you can
see it's really just dispersed throughout the white, almost like it was just injected and smeared around
So I'm a little bit dissapointed in the findings, guys. But I can't say I'm surprised.
I was hoping we'd find a little yellow packet,as like one round ball on the inside
But we still got our caramel egg, so let's o ahead and crack that open, just for fun
Doesn't seen like the liquid nitrogen has affected the foil at all, it peels right off without problem
Oh, wow!
If you look at the chocolate, you can see it's made some interesting patterns, you can see maybe that's the coco butter, it's kind of pushed out to the surface
Of course, it's frosting over pretty quick
But you can see little cracks on the chocolate as well
It's giving it kind of a ornate look
Now just for fun, let's go ahead and crush this in the bench vise
Just going to take this nice and slow
listen closely
Oh that didn't take anything at all
Easy!
Looks like there's an air bubble in here, it's very smooth and shiny
and down here, almost resembles like a geode, like little crystals
A little bit of little chunk of frozen caramel there
How does it taste?
It's like sticking to my tongue a little bit
Wouldn't want to leave that on too long
Very crunchy. The chocolate doesn't taste as good. It tastes a little more waxy than normal. How bizzare
So that was kinda fun, let's move on to the experiment I'm more looking forward too, that is a firecracker in a Cadbury Creme Egg
Now this here is a single stand of Black Cat firecrackers
These are the ones you just light off, and they all go off in series. But I'm going to extract one of  these individually and drill a small hole in the top of the egg
and push it down inside, then light it off to see how it reacts
Let's do that next
yeah, got the yolk on that one
It's a sticky bomb!
So, here's what we got guys, we've got a chocolate Creme Egg with a firecracker stuck down inside
We're going to stick this down on this acrylic base that I made, light it off, and run away. We've got about one second to get some good distance. Let's go
*POP*
Whoo!
Haha! Oh look at that!
*SLOW MOTION POP*
What?! Look at the inside of that egg, It's like thoroughly blended. The white and the orange together to make a new mix
and I think it mixed with some black powder because that's kind of got a burnt orange look to it now
There's the cardboard casing still in there, kinda blasted out of one side didn't it?
Ok, that was pretty cool, let's do that again
*POP*
Whoa!
That was fast!
So it blasted out the top, and then the egg ended up face down, and you can tell the cardboard in there
That one went off a lot quicker than I was expecting
So that was actually kinda fun. I ran probably a lot further away than  I needed too, but it worked
It comes out pretty gooey and half this thing blew off, so I'm really interested to see now what difference it'll make if this is frozen solid
How much more dangerous is that going to be with shards of frozen chocolate shooting out in every direction?
Can't wait to find out
Hoo!
It got me
Cheers!
I think for this experiment, I'm going to try the caramel variety
So quick update guys, I'm giving this thing about two and a half minutes to soak, so it should be sufficiently firm for our demonstartion
The question on my mind though, is will black powder even ignite at such low temperatures, or did we just waste our time?
Let's go light it off and find out!
All right, here we go, nitrogen egg grenade, take one
It stopped
What the heck
That's kind of dissapointing
The fuse burnt out, but the firecracker didn't go off
What the heck
Is that going?
I can't tell if that's the vapor from the nitrogen, or if that's the smoke from the fuse
The fuse is burned away on these, but the cartridge is still inside, so for kicks, let's go ahead and crack these things open, and see what it looks like
There we are
Here's our firecracker
Oh wait! That's weird, It must've cracked off the bottom there
It still looks edible
*Crunching noises*
Crunchy!
Yep.
There's our cartridge completely unscathed
All right, so, interesting. Two times we lit these things off, and two times the fuse burned down, but then stopped without any kind of igniton
So, I'm going to take one of these firecrackers here, soak it in liquid nitrogen by itself and see if we can get it to go off
If it doesn't, then I think our idea of nitrogen egg grenades is probably a dud, let's see what happens
Hot vs cold, which is going to win?
Look at that, ok. So these things won't blow up
All right, we're going to get a little bit gutsy here, see if we can do them all at the same time. Here we go!
*POP*
Woah, they worked!
What the heck
Ok, I wasn't expecting those to actually go off, and the fact that they did makes me wonder if we shouldn't try our last three
and see if we can have any success with those
Why are those working, and those didn't?
What the heck?!
all right, let's make the magic happen
*POP*
It worked! Oh thank goodness, it worked. What was the difference. That's so interesting
Look at this! The acrylic base is still attached, we've got the bottom of the egg frozen to it, and then you just got this half stand of firecracker stuck there in the middle
That looks crazy! That's going to be cool to see into slow-mo.
Oh, gosh
Yeah, that was a lot better than the first one
The combustion was a lot more complete and the explosion took out most of the egg, it wasn't just like some it flopped over sideways
I mean that was a direct hit and shatter in every different direction
That was very satisfying
I'm really glad that worked
The question is if we can get it to do it again
Please work, please work, please work
Whoa! The fuse burned down incredibly fast
Okay, I'm taking a propane torch to it
Now, if this does go off, that's going to be molten chocolate spooring everywhere
Well, I'm calling that a mostly fail. Yeah. *POP* Oh, there it goes! Hahaha! Took long enough
So is was kind of interesting. Let's stop and recap some of the things we did here today
We started off by opening some Cadbury Creme Eggs to see what they look like when they''re gooey on the inside
Then we tried freezing them in liquid nitrogen to see if we could get them to hold their shape before they cracked them open
But it turns out there isn't actually a yolk on the inside them after all, it's just randomly sprayed together
Next, we tried sticking a firecracker down inside one of the Creme Eggs which was very satisfying, but most of the energy came out of the top
So we tried freezing our Creme Egg grenades in liquid nitrogen to see if that'd create a more dramatic effect
We found two things. apparently the fuse to the firecrackers that come off the strips aren't very reliable.
Sometimes they work, and sometimes they don't. When they do work, the results are fantastic.
it worked!
and when they don't, It's a little discouraging.
But I still have a strip full of firecrackers, and two more frozen eggs, so for one grand finale, let's roll them all together
and light them all off
*CONSECUTIVE POPPING*
That's awesome!
Well, that's it for this set of experiments guys, happy Easter, and I'll see you in the next video. Talk to you then
Oh and our eggs still survive